I've got a triangle here for us let's
label some sides and angles shall we
let's call this a B and C so in triangle
ABC we have a right angle in the corner
that's what we've been so far working
with with in trigonometry we also have
an angle and a side okay now on the
basis of this information with
trigonometry in our pocket we can
actually work out absolutely everything
about this triangle you know in
Pythagoras if you wanted to know say a
third side you had to know two of the
other ones or if you wanted to know this
one you had to know these two
but with trigonometry you don't need
that much information this is enough for
instance can you help me work out what a
V is what kind of equation would I write
to help me work out a B Josh 10:30 let's
write that down 10 of course is opposite
on adjacent so that's this guy over this
guy so 10:30 is 5 centimeters over a B
so you can see I can rearrange this a
teeny bit in fact these guys are going
to end up swapping places with your
calculator you could find this like so
can you tell me what that is can you
give me say one decimal place that'll do
8.7 so with that information I can put
this guy on here eight point seven now I
could use Pythagoras that's what we're
so used to doing when you see a writing
with triangle and you've got two sides
but I'm gonna try and keep on using
trigonometry because it seems to work
pretty effectively here if I didn't want
to go to a B what would I write what new
equation could I write to help me get a
see Erin what do you see sign thing
let's all write that down sign
sign of course is which pair of sides
opposite on hypotenuse so I can write
five on a safe just like before I can
rearrange a teeny bit to get this and
interestingly when you press equals
unlike normally when you get strange
unusual decimal rubbish happening when
you get this if my memory is right you
should get exactly ten huh that's
interesting
so we've got this number and we can put
it onto a diagram now red will do
now I've got three sides in a triangle
and I know all of it and there are also
three angles in a triangle
I almost normal from this one of them is
missing which one yeah ACB ACB or BC hey
have a look at the angles that we've got
what is the size of this angle it's give
me sixty degrees how did you find that
angles in a triangle the angle song of a
triangle is 180 degrees so 30 plus 60
plus 19 okay
now you might also notice I gave you
this title write complementary that
wasn't by coincidence
hardly ever is the two angles here that
interesting in this triangle that can
change because we've been dealing with
right angle triangle so it seems we
always a right angle there
these guys are complements of one
another they add up to 90 degrees do you
see that they have to because there's 90
already here there's only 90 degrees
left in the triangle to make up all the
rest so I'm gonna write here
complementary okay now we have ten
thirty we have sine 30 and now we know
there's a 60 degree angle over there but
what I want you to notice is see this
five centimeters on AC we came up with
that as opposite on hypotenuse opposite
on hypotenuse but I can also think of it
as adjacent on hypotenuse if I change
the angle I'm looking at right remember
I told you trigonometry is out of
position so if you change your position
from standing up here that's where the
30 degrees is now I want to stand down
here okay do you see now if I'm from the
perspective of angle ACB this is not up
opposite hypotenuse it's adjacent and
hypotenuse do you agree
so which ratio is that that's cos but
I'm standing in a new angle and what is
its size it's 60 okay now it doesn't
take that much imagination to realize I
could change this triangle I could like
take a and I could squash it down a
little bit and all these angles and
sides would all change accordingly right
but everything we said about position
opposite and hypotenuse adjacent
hypotenuse they'd all stay the same I
haven't changed its rearrangement I just
made it smaller or bigger so all of this
would be the same just with slightly
different numbers okay so here are going
you calculated now see how you say sine
30 equals cos 60 right your calculator
can verify this for you both of them
should give
you are half is that what you find a
half which by the way is the reason why
this came out to be C 5 over 10 it's
exactly a half not just close to it
exactly
now if I squash this triangle down if I
made it like shorter okay this 60-degree
angle might be something smaller suppose
it ended up being instead of 60 suppose
it might be 50 if this angle became
smaller what would happen to the other
angle side sorry angle BAC what would it
become it would not be yeah it would be
bigger than what it was before the wimpy
sine 30 it would be sine 40 now 40 and
50 don't give you nicely numbers but
with your calculator and I'd love it if
the two people like if you're paired up
I'd love what do you work out side 40
and the other one workout cause 50 what
do you get
what's the number damn Z that's fine
okay
so stay with me a tenth so what you're
noticing is if I squash this triangle or
stretched it out I could make this angle
rather than smaller I could make it
bigger
give me another angle that could fit
inside this triangle bigger than 60
anything you like 70 you guys are so
original okay if this is 70 then the
other angle is always going to be
complementary so it'll be 20 right well
again go ahead try with the person next
to you test out sine 20 and cos 70
and you should find the both Lamar 0.20
okay so what's going on here you guys
know I have an obsession obsession with
names right why things are called what
they are okay what you're noticing is
that if you have complementary angles
here 30 and 60 40 50 20 75 and 85 so
long as they complimentary you find the
sign of one is the same as the cosine of
the other and in fact that's exactly
what cosine stands for the KO is short
for Complementary okay so when we say
the cause of some angle right what we
mean is it's the complement of sine you
see that that's what causes an
abbreviation of